let's look at a couple of wacky things
that have come across my desk over the
last couple of days I do want to play
this clip that many of you sent me from
attorney Alan dershowitz who still says
that he is a liberal and that he votes
against Trump but he increasingly has
been a defender of trump from the
perspective of I'm just giving you the
legal argument Alan dershowitz says that
if Trump were to be prosecuted it would
violate the Bible now do we care about
that well that's a different question
you talk about how this is bigger than
Trump about if you're able to do this to
political opponents and dissidents sets
bad precedent it allows prosecutors to
go above and beyond and it actually
makes us less free
without a doubt there was a South
American dictator who said for my
friends everything for my enemies the
law you can use the law to get anybody
as Justice Jackson said or as the KGB
had said show me the man and I'll find
you uh the crime this is the worst
example in my 60 years of practicing
criminal law of targeting somebody for
prosecution and then rummaging through
the books giving people immunity and
trying to concoct a crime that doesn't
exist and if this is allowed to succeed
none of our liberties is safe you know
today it's a republican who's a Target
tomorrow it's a Democrat let me just say
a little bit about this they keep saying
this nobody is safe if Trump is indicted
what you mean is nobody's above the law
Trump's not being indicted if he is
indicted in an absence of any evidence
that he committed wrongdoing we have a
situation where there is evidence and
the fact that he was the president
doesn't put him Above the Law that's a
good thing not a bad thing and the day
after tomorrow it's your uncle Charlie
or your nephew or your niece right
there'd be no limits on what prosecutors
can do to their political enemies and
they're going to do it to people who are
running against them for D.A next and uh
it's just and by the way I think it's
important to say we already see
economically biased prosecution where we
know that there are certain crimes for
which poor people are much more likely
to be prosecuted than rich people we
already have that and the Trump thing
doesn't solve nor exacerbate that
problem
the Trump issue is a different one which
is our president's Above the Law such a
violation not only a violation of
American law and civil liberties it's
actually a violation of the Bible the
Bible instructs Judges two things don't
take bribes that's obvious but the
number one thing is don't recognize
faces and uh that's exactly right yes do
not favor anyone in a court yes that's
exactly right yes continue sorry
no that's and that's why it violates
every core of American value yeah well
fortunately or unfortunately I guess if
you like this argument the Bible is not
controlling the law in this instance
thankfully although if it were up to
Republicans the Bible would actually be
the law of the land and that's a
horrifying reality hypothetically if
there were a court that would hear a
so-called Bible violation then the
Republican party also wouldn't be able
to exist since they regularly violate
the principles of the Bible despite
claiming allegiance to it but that's a
different issue Alan dershowitz once a
widely respected lawyer increasingly a
laughing stock and it really is sad I
don't say sarcastically it said it
really is sad one of our sponsors is
Helix sleep I have been sleeping on a
helix mattress at home for years now I
couldn't be more happy with it I
recommend it to everybody the other day
even though she's not allowed in the big
bed I put my baby daughter on the
mattress and even she loved it Helix
sleep is the premium mattress brand
offering tailored mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences take the
Helix sleep quiz it asks you about your
body type your sleeping position do you
get hot at night do you have back pain
and then Helix will match you with the
mattress that's perfect for you most
people don't know where to begin when
shopping for a mattress including me
Helix makes it simple and less risky
because you know you're getting a
mattress that fits your needs it ships
free you can try it for a hundred nights
to see if you like it and it comes with
a 10 or 15 year warranty unlike many
mattress companies all helix mattresses
are made in the USA by a skilled
production team so you were supporting
good jobs Helix sleep is giving my
audience up to 20 off plus two free
pillows what other mattress company is
going to give you 20 off go to
helixsleep.com Pacman the link is down
below